[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
down
[Music]
pass
[Applause]
[Music]
down
he
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
y
[Music]
what's up everyone it is December 13th
2016 sadly it is the last episode of
this season of the lobby but just this
season not for just this season we'll be
back in what two or three weeks three
weeks I think something like that I
don't know we're all going home for
holidays whatever holiday we're
celebrating um but doesn't mean it's
going to be any slower of an episode we
have a lot to look forward to in 2017
that's going to be the focus of the
episode Rob hanry what's up you're going
to be co-host today cool thanks for
having me yeah I mean you're always on
the lobby anyway but you're like you're
sitting in the Pete brown seat he's
pretty uh swamped today it's a hot seat
yeah yeah he warm like yeah his butt is
like a lot of heat that emenates from it
a man who needs no introduction because
of his vile remarks that's Justin
hayal uh Justin's on so essentially
today we're going to go segment by
segment uh just each platform what's our
like most anticipated group of games for
Nintendo in 2017 Xbox PC
PS4 um we had a few other like minor
games that we've been talking about
recently but we figured you know finale
of the Season we'll uh just kind of look
forward to the next one so yeah let's
start off with Nintendo our most
anticipated games of next year it's kind
of complicated because the Nintendo
switch we're in that transition period
where there aren't a ton of confirmed
games a lot of it might be conjecture
which I'm not averse to getting into um
you know acting like we know what's
going to happen when we have no clue at
all um oh of course we have the entire
slate of Wii U titles coming out next
year I who can forget I could yeah oh
yeah no there there are literally none
except or no there are there Zelda
breath of the wild is going to be on Wii
U yeah that's all you need that's will
be on Wii U first right probably just
dance so they haven't said they've been
really Cy uh about like I felt like when
they first announced it they they had
they had implied they would come out at
the same time so they said Zelda breath
of the wild is going to come out on Wii
U and NX and I think everybody implied
that that meant they would come out at
the same time and they've been very
clear after that after the fact saying
that's not necessarily the case so I
think they're just covering their ass in
case breath of the wild is going to come
out on Wii U and then later on the
switch platform although if it's not a
launch game that's just a huge mistake
they have to do the Wii GameCube thing
where this is the Zelda game that
bridges that Gap was this simultaneous
on Wii and GameCube it was the same day
no no so it came out I actually think it
came out a little bit earlier for Wii
and then it came out afterward for
GameCube and they just mirrored them cuz
I remember I played it on GameCube first
despite the fact it came out afterward
and I liked it on GameCube more just cuz
I didn't have the finicky motion
controls it was still novel experience
at the time but yeah breath of the wild
I remember I was talking to Pete and I
was saying like uh if they do release
simultaneously obviously the switch is
what you want to go for but who knows if
they're going to do that if they just
release on Wii U right away then that's
what I'll play it on because that game
was fun as hell that's probably my not
just my most anticipated Nintendo game
next year that's my most anticipated
game uh all three of us played it at E3
I mean Rob are you like like
historically a big Zelda fan I mean I've
lost touch but I will say that I you
know like aan of time I've beenen like
four times like that
is just an amazing game and I think
about like in my experiences with with
video games like that is just such a
game to adore and yeah everything we've
seen 83 I'm right there with you it it
is by and large like my most ant
anticipated game and you know I'm going
to buy that switch I mean I don't have a
I don't own a wiu so that's where I Fall
in right like I'm part of that market
but it's still weird right like you want
if you're going to I don't know yeah if
you're going to release and launch a
console or they they could do it like
they do with the Wii in GameCube where
they're like we'll put this out on
switch we know that's going to push
consoles and then we'll put it out on
Wii U afterward for people that didn't
want to upgrade but right you have
probably the most well-known video game
franchise at your disposal you might as
well use it to pimp your console but
yeah that the preview at E3 that was one
of the ones where I mean even just from
that I think we all played like an hour
or something 45 minutes and then we all
came back to our E3 War Room the news
like The Press Room and we were all just
like dude did you know you could do this
and then Dave jitt from the UK was like
I like seesaw like catapulted myself up
we're like you could do that what the
[__] and then like just from an hourlong
demo we were doing that I can't imagine
what conversations around this game
right are going to be like when we play
the full 20 to 30 hours whatever it ends
up being uh that's my most anticipated
game period in 2017 it feels like such a
modern Zelda like not just the tablet
whatever thing you have as a character
but it's things like the snowboarding
like just taking your shield and just
snowboarding down and carving up some
slopes I don't know like there's so many
elements of that game that they've
adopted uh that just make it so freaking
exciting I don't know it is weird
because you know they're borrowing kind
of from A Link Between Worlds and and
the idea that you can just tackle these
dungeons in whatever order you want at
least that's what they're saying and
it's like an actual world but at the
same time it it's the closest we've
gotten to the original Zelda you know
like just completely open-ended Zelda
you'd have to find your way and figure
out what you're doing just obviously
technical limitations is not going to be
nearly as big as breath of the wild but
breath of the wild seems like a modern
Legend of Zelda as like the original
Legend of Zelda which is super exciting
for people that like you know there are
people that decry every single Zelda
after like the first game they're the
people that think like every game after
that well they're insane they would have
to be it's it's not you know it's not
like item gating like my favorite Zelda
my favorite game period is Majora's Mask
and it that's nothing like the first
Zelda but breath of the wild looks like
it's taking like modern sensibilities
like to satisfy modern pallets and
combine it with like like a lot of
things like Doom returned to its roots
this year right seems like Resident Evil
might be doing that we'll be talking
about that later in the show uh just a
ton of games like I don't know final
fantasy kind of branched off but a lot
of these iconic franchises seem to be
kind of getting back in touch with what
made them great to begin with which is
exciting well speaking about the
technical limitations of what breath of
the wild will will will other Zelda
games would have been like like there
will have to be some scaling back for
this because this is a game that runs on
Wii U just like the Wii in GameCube
version we don't know a lot about what
the switch's capabilities are but but I
guess some of the games that have been
te is I'm not even sure what we're
getting with them like so we are pretty
sure there's going to be a Mario Kart
experience of some typ there's going to
be a Splatoon experience of some type
and a 3D Mario right and a 3D Mario that
looks completely new but with Mario Kart
and Splatoon are these going to be
updates to an existing game do if you
have them digitally are you going to be
able
to tie into that somehow because it it
has a or we've been told and we've seen
it that it doesn't have a disc system so
you're not going to be able to use your
Wii U disc in this it has to have a
separate cartridge okay right yeah so
what would it be just people thinking
it's a port of the Wii U version to the
switch it doesn't look be what we saw of
Splatoon and Mario Kart didn't look
substantially different yeah it so what
is it going to be you're saying that
like you could you know you could buy
your specific console cartridge or disc
but you're saying are you advocating
that like maybe it's worthwhile to do
like an ehhop thing like would
purchasing the game on like eShop then
allow you to play on both I feel like
they have to I mean Nintendo has always
been really behind on that but they've
also had great backwards compatibility
generally every console has been
backwards compatible with the generation
before that and this is the first one
this is the first major console in a
long time where that's impossible unless
they have some other peripheral so if I
already own Splatoon what's going to
make me want to buy this is is it going
to be a full price game like would that
be a new experience would this be a $20
additional like just competitive thing
like I I'm really curious how that's
going to work like Splatoon is obviously
going to be another game there's going
to be a Splatoon 2 at some point but I
don't think that what we saw when they
teased it was Splatoon 2 that felt like
the Splatoon we already play just with
more competitive options uh to go to
another title Justin you mentioned a
rumor that there might be a third entry
in the Pokemon Sun Moon group on the
switch so so we know they there's that
there's going to be another Pokemon game
they've been clear about that and I I
think the rumor the conjecture right now
is is just like the old Pokemon games
would have a third iteration that came
out about a year afterward uh like uh
Diamond and Pearl would get platinum or
uh red and green got yellow that some
people are conjecturing that we're from
Sun and Moon we're going to get stars or
something along those lines and that
will be a Wii U exclusive version of sun
and moon I have no idea how that would
work like is
that is that just going to be an
upscaled 3DS version because the 3DS
version of sun and moon is already
pushing the 3DS to the limits in a lot
of ways you you don't get a lot of games
that have slowdown on the 3DS but sun
and moon is actually pushing the 3DS a
little too far even on the new 3DS so so
I think that's believable and then uh I
mean as as far as third party titles go
you know people are starting to announce
kind of conf confirm is was Skyrim
officially confirmed as of now or is it
still not it's not official but it's
it's really weird if you have a launch
trailer for a console and you have that
much time on screen dedicated to a game
like Skyrim like I think maybe Bethesda
just not ready to announce it they
wanted to do that on their own time uh
it would be really weird if that is not
a confirmed game but that's really I
think that's really positive in the the
grander scheme because it means Nintendo
is thinking about third parties again
and not just like making separate titles
for the switch but here you know tapping
into the Z gist of what are the big
games right now Skyrim is is huge
getting that onto the switch like that
would be a really crazy amazing
experience you'd have a portable Skyrim
yeah and then to look a little farther
ahead there's uh a couple of smaller
teams announce games for the Nintendo
switch seasons of heaven will be an
exclusive but it's it's not releasing in
2017 despite that being our conversation
this is a 2018 switch exclusive but it's
about it's from a French Studio it's
about Yan a young boy with Asperger
syndrome and his French Bulldog Annie
both characters are playable and
according to a Google translated article
from French game Blog game Blog the
title is currently running on unreal
legent 4 this is all from uh Gamespot
article by Jason IM uh and then also
there is the sacred hero which will also
be on PC but we don't know a ton about
it just it's from a developer
simplistic um but that is also slatest
release in 2018 so that's two of the
smaller titles I did want to look at
possible conjecture uh I think all of us
kind of Hope metroids going to come back
in a big way at some point whether it be
a you know first person like prime or
you know third person this generation we
haven't had a a Metroid game we had
nothing on the Wii U on the 3DS we had
prime Federation Force wasn't a fan of I
don't think I don't think you don't
count that as a
Metroid like going back to that the
first person Roots like this is this
would 100% be the time to do that and
especially in the US like Metroid Prime
was such a such a popular series such a
popular direction to take that Metroid
formula it would be insane not to go
back to that yeah I mean it seems even
more so than the Wii U that switch seems
tailor made for some sort of you know
classic Metroid game between the
handheld options available and the
actual just you know I don't think it'
be that hard to I I'm kind of I'm you
know being reductive but I'm I just want
a 2d Metroid game or even a Prime game I
love the Prime Trilogy even echo which I
think a lot of people say is their least
favorite I just I want a Metroid game
really badly and if breath of the wild
and a Metroid game I'm already sold for
the switch like I really want one and if
they brought a Metroid out next year
that would just be game breaker it would
be weird if they didn't oh sorry is uh
is the switch going to be touch screen
was that confirmed or not I I feel like
they sty yeah I feel like they haven't
said specifically one word the one way
or the other there that's still rumor
it's a conjecture that there is some
Capac POS surface on it which responds
to touch but Nintendo has not said like
I don't think we're going to learn any
more concrete details about the system
until January so yeah January is the
next big like uh news that's when the
next news rolls out for the switch uh
what is the tentative release March uh
tenative releases sometime in March okay
cool W we'll probably we'll definitely
learn that in January so January I think
13th they're going to have a press
conference which you know you can watch
on gamespot.com uh that'll be from Tokyo
and then soon soon after that we're
going to have events all across the
globe so our Australian office our UK
office and here in San Francisco we're
all going to get a chance to uh to try
it out cool so yeah those are the games
we are looking forward to for uh
Nintendo in 2017 let us know if we
missed any in the comments and uh tell
us what you're excited
for all right Justin thanks for uh
sharing your Nintendo expertise as
always I'm gonna boot you off quick for
uh Jake Decker's coming on going to talk
Xbox One something's up with the mic no
nothing wrong Tay's shaking his head
that was a good joke yeah it's just you
know a little red herring for the people
watching uh so yeah these perform with
the right XLR cable so you to switch it
you're picky as hell aren't you yeah he
coming on the show he likes the newer
one Jake what's up not much we're going
to talk about Xbox One games soon but uh
I want to know what are you playing
right now uh I just finished Final
Fantasy I finished Hitman hit man he
does that every time like well I mean
technically there's a there's a bunch of
episodes right it's kind of like a Hit
Men yeah hit men it's a bunch of men no
but he says hit men like no I say Hit
Men I heard hit hit men whatever um and
then I'm gonna start Last Guardian soon
so I'm not playing anything I finally I
think people around the office that I
keep complaining to have been waiting
for me to get to the point where I like
it I'm there I like that game a lot more
oh did you recently cuz this was this
was Monday yeah no no I was complaining
a lot coming in yesterday morning last
night I played another 4 hours I uh I
think there were what 16 chapters I
think I'm on 12 gosh are there even
chapters that's like this this the areas
if you look up so I looked up like Trio
commands to make it a little easier like
I didn't want to obviously look up
puzzle solution no like no Trio commands
they're dude there are like helpful tips
for that game that they don't so I
looked those up and made it much better
and I'm also at the point where past the
point where Trio is just this like
uncooperative pet yes he's still he's
still he still is like a being of his
own but I'm I'm getting much more used
to like dealing with him and dealing
with me it's crazy how I was going
through the exact same thing I mean I
guess it's not crazy but what's it's
just it's crazy how close to F this game
I don't want to play looking forward to
playing this no but it's it's it's
honestly it's weird like and it's hard
to say like whether that's intentional
or not I mean I'd say parts of it
definitely are but there are just
there's just not much guidance so you
just get like again like coming home
after work it could be really hard to
turn that thing on like I'm exhausted
waited a while yeah I played over
weekend but yeah sure enough no it's so
worth it like you get to a point where
it's just you just understand how
everything works and then it starts
speeding up and it is definitely awesome
maybe I'll wait till the weekend to
start then yeah maybe stressed out and
tired or something because that will
exacerbate those feelings um anyway
we're here to talk about our most
anticipated Xbox One games of next year
um some of these throughout the show
today for those watching live we're
going to be kind of crisscrossing
between platforms so some of these won't
be Xbox One exclusives they might be you
know PS4 PC but we're kind of like
diving them up and then these breakouts
will not go up until like the 22nd I
think when we actually start you know
doing our most anticipated stuff on the
site um anyway Xbox one I have crack no
scalebound first scalebound was that
demo at uh E3 was kind of funny for all
of us just between the uh the jargon
that okay so the main character's name
is Drew so it's from Platinum Games you
know Bayonetta U Metal Gear Rising
Revengeance Fame they're also working on
near automata which we're getting into
later in the PS4 segment um yeah this
dude Drew is working with a dragon thuin
or tubin I don't know how to pronounce
it completely but we watched the demo E3
and he was just fighting this massive
boss kind of like a Devil May Cry SL
Bayonetta taking on boss I was about to
say it's almost like coloss very much
the opposite of Last Guardian first tone
yeah yeah I mean between you know the
war cries they have and the you
apparently you can just uh snap into a
first person mode to control the dragon
every once in a while but obviously look
at like looking at this gameplay here uh
you see this giant massive crab boss
rising out of the water that we end up
fighting uh you know bow and arrow
apparently there will be like Firearms
later that degrade over time it's an RPG
action RPG it's build as so you know be
ranking up your character throughout
picking up new weapons I'm sure uh it
looks fun I would say uh especially if
they can kind of nail that Dragon slum
combat almost like Titanfall maybe the
balance between different two different
scals scal bound um yeah what do you
guys think of this game Jake did you uh
play have we has have any of us played
any of this or just I haven't played it
I think it looks cool I remember I maybe
it was this E3 the last E3 they showed a
demo and it was running like garbage
like it was had poor frame rate it
didn't look that good but looking at
this this looks this looks pretty cool I
I I I'm curious like
how long I'd actually be able to play
this though like I feel like it might
get monotonous after a while but I mean
the
scale is definitely there the thing
going for it obviously is platinum games
I mean they it always seems a little bit
monotonous at first just that kind of
basic balance of range and closeup
attacks but then you keep playing these
games like Bayonetta or metal gear
rising and they just keep getting more
nuanced as you go and they know how to
Pace their game so or Legend of Kora
which was pretty bad I didn't play
Legend of they rang so much like I don't
know what to expect with Platinum Games
either it's going to be great or it's
just going to be like kind of dumb yeah
you're totally right I mean again the
most recent thing I played by them was
near automata preview again we're
talking about that later on the show the
live show but it it definitely looks
like something I want to play just
watching this uh you know you get up
close and this is just boss fights
obviously I'm sure not everything is as
big but I don't know what that was I
have a hard time understanding what
exactly you're doing in this game though
it is it an open world I've seen clips
of like you and the dragon like just out
in a field and stuff and then it's these
boss battles what is like the three-word
classification of this game so it's I
mean they're saying action RPG okay so I
don't know that it's going to be open
world uh you know like near automata
will be this might be kind of more a
linear Devil May Cry thing with like
these yeah I feel like we've seen like
sandbox areas for this like yeah cuz
bayonett was entirely linear I remember
there're supposed to be Co-op too right
or multiplayer or something yeah wasn't
it four players taking on that boss
during E3 yeah yeah uh I don't know like
it it looks promising I'd like to see
you know see it in action obviously uh
not sure exactly when that releases I
can check that out but they've been
working on it for a while too definitely
yeah so it's because they announced it a
few years ago right was like what it was
is it like Gamescom or something like
that like years ago yeah there's no
exact release date it's still 2017 for
Xbox One Microsoft Windows so hopefully
we'll hear more about that if not like
before E3 than at E3 or something um
Crackdown 3 which I think everybody kind
of got excited about when they saw the
Microsoft Azure powered uh destruction
uh just essentially You Can level the
whole city if we were running I think
Pete Brown would be good to talk to
about this he understands like the
technical uh components of it but yeah
well it seemed like destroy the city it
was using a Cloud Server type type of
process where like a build each building
in a certain area would be devoted to a
server and operate on the cloud so like
if blowing up one building it would they
basically I think I saw up to like they
had like a a debug and they were showing
like up to like 12 different servers
when like you were leveling like you
know like a whole
block that game looks insane they were
showing like footage of like a guy
basically just like shooting a wall and
was able to create a hole to snipe out
of uh the destructible environment of
that whole city sounds insane ambitious
but they can pull it off definitely fun
I the first Crackdown I played a lot
that was one of my early Xbox 360 games
that was like that in Call of Duty 2 if
I recall correctly I did not like the
second one all that much it felt really
repetitive in what you were asked to do
but yeah just once you start getting all
those agility orbs and just this is like
a behind the scenes documentary watching
but once you get all those agility orbs
You' leap like up 20 story buildings
with one jump you just become so
overpowered in the best way and uh
combining that with these destructible
environments that they're promising
would sounds pretty awesome well like if
you see one on a building would you just
level the building and then pick it up
off the ground yeah it's like uh it's
kind of the opposite of what I would
want to do is destroy everything um and
Tack on the fact that it was it I
believe it was Co-op that they they
showed footage of like um I forget where
I saw it but uh yeah all of them have
been Co-op so I'm pretty sure this one I
mean it makes sense for this one to be
Co-op as well it' be weird that's one of
its tenants I would be I would be
surprised if they uh kind of just did
without it this time yeah Crackdown was
like one of the first sort of open world
games that had Co-op I thought that was
so cool and came out like you do like I
don't know land connection and just like
be screwing around the city with a
friend yeah it took a while to wrap your
head around the fact that you could do
that with games back in like 2007 or
whatever it was but yeah this looks
promising to say the least it's just I
don't know know other games have kind of
like tried to do this yet with the cloud
uh so I'm looking forward to seeing what
happens just this domino effect theity
obviously this is pre-alpha but I'm
really curious to see what they end up
doing with like NPCs or creating people
in this city right because
sure leveling it would be a whole lot of
fun but you know just people going about
their daily business or is it just empty
you know I mean it won't be that
obviously but I'm just curious to see
like the actual City like operation what
was the deal with the first two games
there were NPCs all over the city right
there weren't or like not many right
there weren't many a l the second one
there was like a zombie outbreak or that
was the whole thing you were going to
these zombie nests and then figuring out
how to destroy those um I don't know
what the actual like civilian population
was like I imagine the first game wasn't
n too populated if it was like a early
Xbox 360 game mhm and I'm looking
forward to that though yeah another one
we have listed here which is not just
like XBox One exclusive prey which I am
really really excited for mainly because
I love Dishonored 2 which I just
finished and it's also Arcane Studios is
following in the vein of uh you know
looking glass games DSX Thief System
Shock that kind of first person choice
and consequence uh you know like story
driven Adventure um Des to is you know
we keep talking about it around the
office it's uh a great game that we
really enjoyed I myself really like I
loved the first Dishonored um prey is
the other side of Arcane studio so
Harvey Smith being creative director of
uh dishonor 2 ref Cole Antonio over in
France will be heading up prey or is
heading up prey uh I can't wait for this
I mean it's cool like the story itself
the premise is cool so essentially it's
based on the fact that JFK survived the
assassination on uh
112263 and then like like continued
pouring funds into space research so to
the fact to the point where we were
actually like pretty Progressive in
space and then aliens took notice and
you are Morgan U on a space station
which again this is all just System
Shock like on a space station the
original prey on 360 which I didn't play
much I think people kind of consider a
cult classic right I I played it yeah I
remember being sick cuz you'd like run
up like upside down and like be around
that was like a launch title wasn't it
it was close to launch I think it was
like a couple months after so yeah but I
mean this one you can transform into
coffee mugs you can you know just to get
through space it just looks wacky it's
it seems like dishonor too but obviously
sci-fi and just on acid also dark like
the the whatever alien villain it is in
this game looks creepy as all hell like
like something out of a dream nightmare
me I can't wait for this I mean it seems
like combining kind of the isolation of
alen and and you know that choice driven
uh gameplay of Dishonored those games I
mentioned the Looking Glass vein of
games that people have been so uh
affected by even like origin systems
back in the day I can't wait for this
this uh I don't if this has an
actual release date yet I think prey is
uh yeah I mean 2017 right now but I it
just looks like it's going all out like
batshit crazy with things you could do
and then obviously you're getting like
these sci-fi weapons that are becoming
kind of iconic I uh I never I didn't
play that original one the the story too
like it seems more interesting than
dishonor too like dishonor world I think
is is one of the best things about that
game but the story was kind of weak in
this at least judging by like the
trailer they've showed they've shown the
premise seems super interesting like I
feel like they could do something really
cool with this story yeah definitely uh
again this is not a XBox One exclusive
per se it's on PS4 and Microsoft Windows
as well but figured we would slide it
into this segment because
uh we got a lot of PS4 and Xbox One
games to talk about but anyway I don't
know about you guys you missed anything
else I mean we we're talking about Mass
Effect Andromeda on the PC section uh
Yuka leele do you guys play were you big
fans of banjo kazui and Tui yeah I
definitely uh played banjo kazui um I
played that what they call it the toy
box or something Toy
Box um I don't know I mean granted that
was just you know essentially the
ability just to kind of try out the
movement and get a general very general
idea of maybe you know what that game
would feel like
um I I don't know I you know people it's
it's was it crowdfunded or or uh yeah I
mean that's that's all good I think
people are really excited for it and I'm
definitely like happy people are I just
don't see much value personally out of
it I mean it just looks exactly like
banjo kazui yeah I'm excited for it but
yeah like you said it's I'm excited
because it's kind of Reviving The 3D
platformer which is you know all but
almost disappeared in recent years
except for like knack or that has a
sequel so maybe it is coming back who
knows but I played about an hour of this
actually when I was over in London um
platonic showed me a section of the game
they just kind of let me wander around
and collect uh I forg what the it so
obviously it was like Jiggies jigsaw
pieces in Banjo kazui and Tui I was
collecting like pages in this um it felt
really good um some camera issues which
like 3D Platformers you know are made or
broken by their their cameras like The
Last Guardian um
but I'm looking forward to it um it's
this again this isn't XBox One exclusive
it's a releasing on all platforms but
yeah yeah I totally was going to say
that um that was the one like major
gripe where like you know at what point
for like any kind of third person game
do you do you allow you know a a camera
to like Auto turn or Auto auto follow
because it felt like you were really it
was really stiff in that uh Toy Box at
least I played um like you just felt
like you were fighting the camera and it
was getting lodged in like walls and
stuff um hopefully they address that and
then uh one I do want to mention as well
uh I didn't really have a ton of fun
with the first Battlefront not the first
Battlefront but like the 2015 reboot the
EA Battlefront they are slated for 2017
release or at least like rumored or
whatever uh Battlefront 2 will be
releasing um I don't know what to expect
from it I think we've heard some things
about this I don't know what we're
supposed to talk about yet so I'm not
even going to risk anything but well
yeah I mean I know what I want what do
you want I want campaign yeah duh yeah
uh I want like a galactic Conquest type
of idea with that uh cuz that was most
addicting part yeah oh my god oh in both
those games Space Battles would be great
just being able to switch sides and just
like have a completely different like
tone to everything I mean Rogue One
releases in two days you have Force
awakens out already we know like it just
seems like Star Wars is in fullon push
it seems weird not to take advantage
of of all these new stories excuse me
that are kind of coming out in each
these movies a campaign would make sense
and and that is the biggest uh I would
say maybe an overall like gripe with
like a lot of these Star Wars games
lately and you could even vouch for like
some of the latest movies
is this is a franchise that I think I I
don't even want to call it franchise a
universe that so many people adore
however what's getting tiresome is
seeing so much of that original trilogy
like come on let's take some Liberties
let's push things things forward yeah uh
you know Battlefront lacked in that and
even some of the DLC that came
afterwards uh just like the last one is
like an an X-Wing you're in space and
what do you get to fly just an X-Wing
yeah come on like this is like be there
are so many things as far as an Arsenal
that you could have and and create that
I just you're just not seeing a lot of
creativity in and uh you know and that
you know you could also vouch that
that's the reason why Lucas film maybe
that's the roadblock right like you have
to like go through them and it's very
tight and as it should be you know it's
Canon you got to like adhere to the
rules but you imagine EA and dice though
could probably get that get access to
that pretty easily though you know like
well like and just to keep vamping on
that uh the uh Star Wars X-Wing um VR
mission that came out with Battlefront
those guys who made the game were able
to basically design an X-Wing cockpit
and then show it to Lucas film and they
said that's awesome this is now Canon
yeah like I interviewed those guys at
one of the last preview events and it
was freaking awesome like there are
people who are I feel like kind of
taking that route but I'm just sick and
tired of like an AT-AT like thank you ho
can we get off that planet and just
maybe the idea of like an atat and
Walker salt like just like an
unbalanced I don't know premise that
it's just tired it's just been done like
I just want Battlefront to be something
new well what about so the original
Battlefront 2 they started incorporating
the prequel trilogy that's fine by me
yeah if it's just like all military
stuff then that's fine as long as you
don't get too much into the story of the
prequels that's where you kind of enter
Rocky Waters but do you think that you
just played DLC recently can you talk
about it yet yeah absolutely was Rogue
one it was Rogue one yeah so do you
think they'll take more advantage that
in Battlefront 2 because from I'm
reading early reviews from all like
major Publications saying Rogue ones
pretty good right and there's apparently
like the third act well I won't even say
it but like apparently there's a lot of
cool like choreographed battles and like
special effects and the battles
themselves are actually much larger
scale than you might think based on
trailers in Rogue one that we've seen so
far I wonder if they'll take advantage
of that with Battlefront 2 yeah and I
think a lot of it is just time like you
know you look at Battlefront I think
even frankly this DLC wasn't all that
outstanding to me and you just get the
real obvious indication that these are
games that were
that were stripped of a single player
campaign in order to make force awakens
deadline right like once I think
hopefully you know like you have uh like
respawn working on some the Star Wars
title like once we can get I'd say like
another year in maybe Battlefront like
they're hopefully they're doing you know
a lot spending a lot more time on it
yeah then we can start start seeing some
really cool Star Wars games uh I just
feel like now it's
like it's back Star Wars is back let's
like mass-produce this franchise is like
a Marvel case and games are like falling
behind it and that's the problem is like
you know game doesn't like come out in a
year sure like this isn't really
platform Centric but obviously like the
Star Wars game that Amy henig is working
on I can't wait for that I don't know if
it's going to be 2017 or not um that
used to be 1313 uh she's working on with
visceral Studios so we'll see what uh
happens with that maybe we'll hear more
about that next year but of course
that's going to be very narratively
driven knowing Amy hen's experience with
you know like the Uncharted franchise as
example that's exciting yeah so
obviously we wish we had more time but
those are a handful of our favorite X or
our most anticipated Xbox One games
coming out in 2017 so if we missed any
or we have any major ones that you
wanted to talk about leave your thoughts
in the comments below State of Decay
State of Decay yeah we'll get to that
another time that's only that's Xbox oh
yeah State of Decay 2 is
uh yeah XBox exclusive yeah we have more
time we can talk about it but uh on a PC
is it on PC too we can talk on PC is on
Windows it's probably I'll check that
out but first we'll start with uh Mass
Effect Andromeda is an easy hold on let
me intro this better um all right our
most anticipated PC games of
2017 uh I want to start with Mass Effect
Andromeda again this isn't the only
platform it's releasing on but I think
it's the one that like most of us will
play it on just in terms of uh graphical
Fidelity and whatnot uh Jake you're a
huge Mass Effect fan what are you
excited for most with
Andromeda I am most excited for a return
to sort of the RPG route roots that the
series was kind of known for it sounds
like they're taking that and they're
expanding on that even bigger like the
planet diversity is a lot a lot more
planet there's a lot more diverse
planets there's a lot more room to
explore uh the moo well the moo isn't
back it's but there's a ground vehicle
you can use to explore uh my I mean I
I'm super excited for this game I can
ramble about this for a long time yeah
so for those who aren't haven't been
following it feverishly you play as
either Sarah or Scott Ryder just pick
your gender and go with it uh as like it
replaces Commander Shephard you're sent
on the Andromeda initiative obviously
it's like our closest neighboring Galaxy
despite the fact that it's still how
many light years away I forget I did an
entire article on it like what science
tells us about the Andromeda galaxy
we're supposed to mesh like how far into
the future yeah there essentially
there's a super Collision that's going
to happen and it's crazy tomorrow it's
just it's tomorrow yeah the Andromeda
galaxy is just on our doorstep no it's
crazy actually like uh I was reading up
on it a lot I did way too much research
for this like 800w article but
apparently when these galaxies start
colliding and absorbing each other the
the Suns will form a black hole at the
center but each individual planet in the
solar system is so far apart from the
next they won't Collide at all in fact
like it'll be it won't even affect each
other that much the gravitational pull
won't affect so it just be this massive
Galaxy that's formed and then everything
will get sucked into the black holes and
then shot into like other dimensions
essentially like at such high speeds and
distances that like they're not going to
be planets anymore they're going to be
these rocks floating in there so Earth
Earth itself will just be like I I'll
survive you guys probably won't but um
no I just kidding um oh there you
serious uh but yeah also like a big
difference with like you said they're
going back to RPG routs the first mass
effect did have more of those as opposed
to like two which was kind of RPG SL
Third Person cover based shooter which
three I felt went more toward action
cover yeah I mean they did bring back
some of the RPG elements with three but
it was like had like giant set pieces
the explosions and stuff like that um
and but what makes Mass Effect at least
why I love Mass Effect so much are The
Quiet Moments like when you're on your
ship when you're talking to people and
it sounds like they are doubling down on
that like there's different I mean
you're going to have uh there's like the
ship the Tempest which you can explore
and then there's another ship the ark
which is sort of like the Hub area in
this game and it sounds like there'll be
plenty of those character-driven moments
which is what I'm looking forward to the
Tempest is your Normandy for all intense
purches right yeah so it's the
replacement of the Normandy and then the
Nomad is That's The Nomad is the
replacement of the mo it's where you're
going to make sweeth hot love to aliens
with probably tentacle hair hopefully
there is also the fact that you don't
have to pick between those three classes
or three hybrid classes at the beginning
you just start as Sarah or Sky Rider and
then you just build out your skills
however you want them it's almost like a
uh uh what's the run in uh Dark Souls 2
and Dark Souls 3 the Dark Souls Series
where you're deprived run where you
start with like no skills no pre like no
predetermined path you can just build
however you want apparently that's how
Andromeda is going to be more along
those I actually I wouldn't be surprised
it seems like the way it's going but
then like Jean lukan actually did like a
trailer breakdown and if you notice like
classes would have different color uh
Shields at least in the main game or at
least in one two and three or two and
three and then in this one like the
shields are different sometimes
sometimes they're blue sometimes they're
purple that's like a little detail
but um that's yeah I don't know the uh
that's the thing that's has me most
excited for this game actually is just
because I mean the first one was more of
an RPG right but it also still felt
pretty clunky like I I I loved how two
kind of took that those third person
elements and uh you know cover-based
shooting and made that you know let me
enjoy those quieter moments more because
the comat wasn't so frustrating and the
make was coming back like you said but I
don't know if I want that like if they
can make it fun like I know there are
people that just love the moo I can't
stand those so I hated the moo in the
first one but it I mean it seems like
they're taking the steps they need to
make this moo or Nomad actually pilot
like it should drive like it should and
I would argue though that you didn't
hate the moo you hated the barren boring
planet or the like fortresses you had to
assault that had like six turrets on
this gate and then you go through every
room was six turrets was just a crates
inside of it right and then there's one
like new helmet you got out of it I
would I would like I mean you know this
just dreams but I would really like that
ability like I think two kind of did a
lot of that where you were I thought it
was cool was like just probing a planet
like I have no problem having that like
no man's Skai boring ass Planet as long
as you don't have to land on it right
yeah like if there was the solution of
like hey this is actually a pretty
habitable or Lush planet with like um
you know a bunch of Krogan on on it like
cool now I can I can know I know that if
I land there I can spend a lot of time
there and talk to people and get stories
and stuff like that that direction was
like what I loved about two yeah I don't
want to land on like andromeda's version
of North
Dakota no offense to viewers of North
Dakota it just doesn't seem like there's
much going on in a lot of that state or
like Antarctica exactly that would be a
less offensive one no one any Planet no
man Sky yeah that was harsh yeah we all
just took Digs at certain States and
games um all right moving on from that
this one I'm actually really excited for
I don't know if either you guys have
played Divinity original sin let me
restart that Divinity original sin
Divinity original sin 2 from larryan
Studios the Belgian developer is
releasing next year I played a bunch of
previews this game I love the first one
it's actually it's not underrated people
praised it very very highly it was
gamespot's PC game of the year uh two
years ago 2014 if I'm not mistaken and
then uh it's just isometric like Old
School West RPG uh party based combat
and
exploration it and then the combat
becomes turn-based but if you guys are
into that at all you should play the
first one to get ready for this because
this game looks unreal actually like
full disclosure Kevin vanord former
reviews editor gam spot is writing
helping write this game yeah um you know
like it's a fantasy RPG and uh there's
also like PVP elements to this which
didn't sound like anything I wanted but
I played a few previews actually really
fun like it's you get uh three
characters against three and it's or no
you get one versus one they might be
introducing new maps but you get uh like
like a these lizard characters of like
an new Undead class that's in this game
uh as you're building out your party and
then you can you know like the combat in
this game is awesome it's all
experimentation based and all kind of
like uh cause and effect right like so
there's this Barrel up on top of this
scaffolding and then knowing this Mage
is better at a distance and from a
height you lob you predetermine that
you're going to lob like a Fire Grenade
or a fireball onto it so then when they
go up it'll just be burned they'll have
to come down which will allow your
Warrior to get up close it's I'm like
kind of being reductive right now but
there are a lot of nuance and a lot of
layers to its combat that actually makes
the PVP really fun obviously just based
on this gameplay right here if you
played the first one you know it can be
pretty menu heavy uh text Heavy if
you're ready if you're just like ready
to get really absorbed in a game play
the first one because it it's really
rewarding the story is great the
characters are awesome and obviously
like the main character being the one
you're fleshing out um two looks looks
fantastic and I cannot wait for this um
it is yeah Slater for 2017 but I hope it
comes very
soon um anyway do you guys have any
thought you don't have any thoughts
about Divinity I think I you played it
un I'll keep pimping it if you want no
no that sounds I'm really excited for
that game it looks great it awesome
plays great from what I played um py uh
super giant games of Bastion and
transistor Fame it's their newest game
looks like a football game at first but
it's also an RPG it's also this third
person Adventure it's pretty fun from
what I played have you guys got hands on
with it at all uh no i' I've seen a lot
of it I mean stylistically and it's it's
art style it looks wild and like just
wacky and and not wacky I would say but
very original you can't different from
the other stuff yeah you can't really
like point at any kind of era almost I
don't even know what it is no to when
I'm trying to describe the genre to
people I say imagine a turn-based combat
RPG where the combat is fantasy football
and a big space in between those those
words where the combat is football set
in a fantasy world not fantasy football
you're not [__] like getting together
to draft people um yeah you get you get
three characters to begin with I I think
it expands later but of course like
there's a small one who's really good at
dashing has extra Dash and then you're
just passing this ball around trying to
get it into the other players like end
zone for on intens and purposes but then
the maps become more intricate it turns
out it's like this tournament to like
free yourself from slavery so it has
like Gladiator aspect right it's like
Russell Crow trying to open his shackles
and whatnot but you know but then you
have like this huge story between you
have this Camp you go to to upgrade your
characters and kind of build new items
and whatnot you know the RPG elements in
between uh the writing the art style is
gorgeous like even just these characters
that pop up during the dialogue look on
Amazing it you could definitely tell
it's like inspired by transistor and
transistor and Bastion and you know what
really threw me off in a really great
way that was the music I found the music
uh
like to have a very like interesting
contrast with like everything that was
going on because it has a very like
fantasy element to it but like I
remember hearing like almost like a like
a rock distorted Bas Groove that was
just felt made it made it feel like a
space froner type of type of uh style
yeah and it's weird because you see one
of the more intricate Maps here and you
have like the large character you have
the the main one in the middle you have
the smaller one that scampers around uh
it becomes a little more it's like rock
paper scissors at first and how you
attack someone with a ball or defend
from it but then it becomes more about
kind of the overarching structure of the
game is really appealing to me because
these bides the actual combat or the
actual events what you want to call them
sporting events that's like the the
bite-sized things that you just really
learn the intricacies of a pretty simple
game like gwent or you know like chess
which seems simple at first but then you
realize how complicated it can be but
then you have this like overing RPG and
it's not open world you're going from
point to point along a map from what I
remember and that's where like the you
know like umbrella story comes into play
and kind of contextualize it all and
makes it memorable from a story
narrative perspective uh I can't really
explain it much better than that it's
weird you have to like play it like
right here see you're lining up a power
blast you get the ball and you just have
to carry it to their end zone without
them stopping you it's a really really
fun game animation looks so freaking
cool it's like transistor itself was
almost hard to describe too of how they
approach turn-based combat and whatnot
but yeah py I can't wait for this uh
super giant games they haven't never
made anything less than great uh so I'm
looking forward to that uh last thing I
want to touch on for PC title in 2017 is
one that's been ongoing for quite a
while but Rob you finally just dug in
recently to Star Citizen I think because
of no man sky and Elite danger has kind
of peaked interest in this I played a
demo at Gamescom yeah um I'm kind of
looking forward to seeing what content
they come out with see how much closer
getting to that ideal Vision that we all
have of it yeah like the first person
shooting the gravitational like zero
zero g combat in outer space finding
this hover bike going out to a planet to
help your friends fight this pirate base
all seamlessly you know which has become
such a buzzword recent months but I'm
looking forward to I don't do we know
like it specifically so yeah I mean
sometime 2017 right this talk right now
should be like a a grain of salt just
because it's like definitely like you
can definitely say it's not coming out
next year but um former gam spot uh
video producer Josh Shaw and I played
the other day and what they are doing is
they're they're about to to launch God
dang I can't remember the patch number
but it's supposed to address um a lot of
the main issues that game which is for
me having played it uh it's just the
optimization I mean you're you're
looking at like just like 10 frames a
second like it is almost unplayable but
what what is that I mean I think a lot
of people don't understand or are unsure
they've gone pretty far so so far I
would say like you can do a lot of cool
stuff um you get a general idea I mean
by no means this is even close to done I
don't think but yeah just to uh to say
what yeah what you were saying is I
don't know what the update will the
update will exactly bring but I'm pretty
sure it's the ability to do like two
three missions with your friends like
basically meet up with them at different
locations across I believe just maybe a
solar solar system more space stations
to explore which will give you many more
missions in a update 3.0 3.0 which is
not released yet but that's the one I
saw at Gamescom and they showed me it
like there were a few technical hitches
I remember I like wrote really extensive
preview about it but there were a few
technical itches but that was the thing
they were worried about was the fact
that this character like wasn't holding
a glass correctly it didn't look real
that's what they're worried about at
this point they're just fine-tuning it
uh the connection looked great granted
it was all in one room might have been
Lan at that point
uh you're seeing like a like Chris
Roberts and like three people from cloud
Imperium games were showing me the demo
okay and it was so that two people on
the monitors over here someone on the
main one and they were showing me like
he these two woke up on the space
station these two were already fighting
these Pirates down on this planet yeah
uh I forget how long away and of course
the light speed jumps are real time not
our real time but in the game like uh
the light speed jumps are like
calculated so they will actually take
you know like if they're going however
many light years it'll still take 10
minutes to get there if you're going
that far but they were in like a
neighboring star cluster or something so
it didn't take that long so they got
there saw this you know defunct pirate
ship up in orbit around this planet
where they're two Co-op teammates all in
the same instance like already in a
co-op game but not in the same planet in
the same area they saw like knew they're
on the planet they were talking to each
other they went got this hover bike off
this ship after killing a few Pirates
brought it their ship down and then
ejected the hover bike over the uh
atmosphere and then they landed on the
hover bike and then it just started
careening out of control and Chris
Roberts saying I when it's ready that
will not happen but it was still cool
cuz then they just went to the pirate
Bas and helped them out these two have
been fighting for like 20 minutes and
the other two started like woke up grabb
the mission from the guy while these two
were already in the planet yeah that
that just like uh you know like that
mission spanning the Galaxy or spanning
that solar system at least just sounds
so cool to be in a co-op game but you
were on Jupiter I was on uh I don't know
Mercury might be burning alive but let's
not get into the science yeah that's
really where it's at right now it's just
like a couple of disjointed pieces you
know like you can only do this like
right now we last time I played it was
like oh yeah you can just kind of
venture out to this comms array and jump
start it with a with a couple buddies
but what was funny was what happened we
had this random guy get on the ship and
we told him to like fly it he was his
name was Agent Cody and Josh all was
like Agent Cody fly the ship he's like
I've never flown a ship this big we were
just like chatting and the time of our
life we get there Pirates blow our ship
up I get a jettison this dark deep space
I'm in chat saying
gravity yeah I was like some someone
come save me some random guy was like
all right on my way out took him like 10
minutes he gets out same Pirates kill
him yeah like thanks for the try he's
like yeah whatever that's what excites
me about that game so far my uh you know
brief experience is it's always been
like a pretty good Community just like
not that many people in it but I mean
there are a lot of people playing this
this game has a lot of money and you
know it's constantly criticized for
when's it actually going to be out but
the thing I keep telling people is they
never promised it's ever going to be
like this retail release it's people are
paying for this like rolling out of
updates you know I don't think they're
great with the time of the updates I
think they could kind of make better or
at least less concrete promises about
when they're going to release because
this was supposed to be December from
what I remember uh now it's not out yet
but hopefully in the next few months
like 2017 will be you know start citizen
will be closer realizing what that ideal
vision is that we all have for it I'm
sure Chris Roberts has for it too yeah
but anyway cool so those are the PC
games we're were most looking forward to
in 2017 if we missed any I'm sure we did
any big ones any small ones mention them
in the comments below
all right Jake I'm going to boot you off
for Pete Brown Pete Brown's usually on
here the whole show but he's been
swamped today and he's too cool for the
lobby uh he's coming on right
now even looks cool walking on I was
doing the Rob walk for for people
listening got like a fzy thing going
Fonzy thing going on it's like fzy fzy
is that what I said fzy I'm sick been
coughing I think we're all sick I'm I
had a whole weekend of staying in my
place watching two and a half seasons of
The
Wire it was amazing it was like so
relaxing I just cleaned I had headphones
on I was
vacuuming anyways I talk you were in bed
what are you talking about I was both
impressive it was both that was that was
Sunday and then Friday Saturday it was
sick yeah anyways all right we're going
to talk about the most anticipated PS4
games of the Good Year of Our Lord 2017
our Lord
201 yeah praise be to 2017 uh there's a
Bunch coming out that I needed to bring
p on for cuz I'm not going to play these
I'm just kidding I'll try to play them
um yeah so there are a few that we
haven't mentioned that would have been
an Xbox and PC but of course they're
multiplatform games we wanted to spread
them out we'll start with those uh Red
Dead Redemption 2 it's not a PS4
exclusive at all but it's one that a lot
of people are excited for Anytime
Rockstar releases something it's a big
deal we did that whole live stream event
to watch the trailer the trailer is more
of a teaser it didn't show Too Much
showed this gang of seven people uh the
obvious comparison being like
Magnificent Seven or something uh
they're riding across what you had said
would be kind of the original map's
Northeast section and then like up
through the Rockies so it'd be more
Midwest it seemed like it yeah seemed a
lot more Lush right like a lot more
Wildlife well the map the map leaked and
it really is it's like if you continued
from the northeast of the original Games
map up that's what Red Dead Redemption 2
is so you're just going toward the
Rockies I guess who knows what's going
to happen there all kinds of crazy [__]
happens Rockies gunfights so Buffalo B
are here haven't been killed off yet
that's my favorite shot there's going to
be snow it looks like more the cold
weather uh I think we did like a what we
want from Red Dead Redemption 2 and my
uh you know this is never going to
happen thing but I still want it anyway
was Grand Theft Auto 5's character
swapping the zooming out and zoom back
in on Franklin Michael or Trevor but
with seven people in one gang what you
okay need that a lot of people you don't
need that um you don't need that many
people in Oceans 11 you don't need that
many people in magnificent seven you
don't need that many people in hateful
eight but they did it anyway we're
talking about movies or video games
movies but we could talk about video
games uh you didn't need that many
people and grand out out five three was
all right like one F seven people had
lock down and four he didn't need other
people but cool idea F I think I'm more
inclined to think that and that's the
other thing we talked about was that
it's an online component or like you and
seven buddies get on your horses yeah
and you venture yeah well yeah like the
cops and robbers kind of stuff in Grand
Theft Auto 5 would work great for Red
Dead Redemption yeah cops and robbers
yeah use Outlaws and DEP deputies even
just Grand Theft Auto online right even
just Grand Theft Auto online's like
premise currently makes more sense in
the wild west right like the biker gangs
with horses yeah but just you know
having it be you know a ruthless
unorganized unpoliced part of History
opposed to like just a whole city just
that's on fire yeah not that La isn't
already but I don't know saying I was
just saying I'm not up to date on
current events no I'm just saying I
would love to just you know walk into
the street turn around see like Rob's
character staring at me with his handing
over his gum gun I look just like the
gang from Clockwork Orange with a bower
hat and white onesies and overalls
underwear over it then you approach me
go back to the bar drink milk afterward
mhm um no anyway that would be great to
see kind of some sort of yeah like you
said kind of like cohesive Cooperative
experience where I you could form gangs
and roam around it would seem weird not
to based on what they've done with Grand
Theft Auto 5 the biker gang update maybe
you were saying you even thought that's
like kind of a test subject to maybe do
it in Red Dead Redemption 2 maybe not
that far but might be kind of you know
just proof of concept I mean Grand Theft
thought online is the reason why you
don't have single player DLC right like
it's a success like they made a lot of
money and they will continue to so it
just makes sense to test those Waters
with other ideas yeah uh looking forward
to it definitely we talking about like
where the story might go you're going to
be it did look like it was John marsten
and uh was one of those characters and
then uh Bill the rest of his gang that
you're hunting down at the beginning of
the first game seems like they're going
to be incorporated somehow maybe it's a
did we discover if it was a prequel or
not that was just based on the fact that
he it must be a preview or a prequel if
like those characters we mentioned are
all together as a right because you see
shots of him on a ranch which I guess
you presume even from the vo that it's
his I think meaning maybe that's this is
what these events make him spiral down
into who he was in the first game yeah
who knows looking forward to that uh
also Horizon zero Dawn which will be a
February release uh February is kind of
packed it's Yakuza zero is Valentine's
Day for honor is Valentine's Day forizon
Horizon zero Dawn I forget what what
exact day it is but they're all February
it's kind of loaded no no no I'm sorry
Yakuza is January 24th with resent evil
uh which we'll also talk about res evil
right now um Horizon zero dawn looks
pretty cool it seems like Far Cry in
third person to me where you hunting
robot
dinosaurs yeah but hopefully the robot
aspect is something fresh yeah right I
think there's a lot of opportunities
there for you to mix and match parts and
create weapons and and find
vulnerabilities in the different robots
which you know the game looks really
impressive but that aspect is definitely
the thing that has me the most
interested there there must be some sort
of in-depth crafting that would make
sense because like it seems like you're
trying to survive at least one like
under the watchful gaze of these huge
robot cyborg dinosaurs it would make
sense to actually like gather parts from
them to craft new things cuz they've
showed some parts where she's us using
using primitive Weaponry kind of like
you know like more Stone Age kind of
stuff or Bronze Age and whatnot but then
there are later things they showed where
it looks like she was kind of you know
making use of her environment a little
more which that would be an interesting
aspect to me but the overall like kind
of cascading waterfall structure of
quest as far as um there were those like
brosaurus that once she hacked it or
something along those lines or at least
an ancient version of it it looked like
it opened up a new area of the map so
maybe it's like the watchtowers from Far
Cry but kind of roaming around I I I
hate to keep comparing it to Far Cry but
these things when she climbed up this
and like hacked into it it looked like
it revealed part of the map nearby it's
like Trio you just climb on top of his
head and jump to the next area yeah we
were My Last Guardian earlier on the few
segments I don't know speaking of heads
I love that like USS Enterprise thing
stacked on the neck it's just like such
a it's like we're doing it it's such a
weird blend of like honest like Stone
Age and futuristic robots it's awesome
like I think that's what captivated our
attention at first but yeah I'm hoping
the story there is really good because
they've kind of hinted at it but we
don't really have that much to go on at
the moment yeah the demos we played that
we just dropped into smaller kind of
sandbox areas uh I think Scott and Jake
both played I haven't played yet I'm
looking forward to it I kind of at this
point I might as well just wait for the
full game but uh regardless It looks
interesting um yeah I just mentioned it
Yakuza zero the prequel to The First
Yakuza yes uh okay so you are a Yakuza
fan yeah I sort of been admiring from
the sidelines for a while I played some
of the uh one of them on PlayStation 3
um but yeah like it's it's a it's such a
strange series cuz it uh there's like
two there's like the really goofy
ridiculous wacky half that plays like
kind of like a like a like a little bit
of a shy arcade game but it has its
charm because it's not really meant to
be that that like involved right you're
basically just bashing heads and like
beating people up in really grotesque
funny ways and then you have this other
half with these really serious uh you
know cinematic story moments that are
inspired by by Yakuza films and it's
just a it's just a really interesting
mmch because you can you can appreciate
it for for what it is in both ways right
like the game knows that it's being like
dumb and silly when it's being dumb and
silly so you you it's not even that you
have to forgive it it's just that you
you pivot and you play a different game
for a minute until you get to the next
story beat um and the series has done a
great job of that so far uh so
interesting to see uh you know how zero
sort of sets everything up yeah because
then Yakuza 6 releases 2018 correct
right and then we're also yeah and we're
also getting Yakuza kiami at some point
which is the remake of the original okay
there's a lot of Yakuza games coming
which is awesome because for a while it
didn't look like we were going to get
these there is one that we will probably
never get called Yakuza isan I think or
een it's uh set in like Ado Japan and uh
okay yeah I don't think we're gonna get
that one you'll be reviewing Yakuza zero
when it releases in January you know it
cool I've never played any of those I
played dead Souls a little bit dead
Souls which is like way different
spin-off right yeah way Ian you have
guns in that right yep yeah you don't
have guns in these games Peter showing
me clips of uh Yakuza zero and uh what
sold me was the karaoke just walking in
and you just like dish out some songs
and get out and just continue on it
looks it just looks so great yeah it's
it's actually this game is so similar to
shenmu that I feel like people need to
kind of forget about shenmu 3 for a
while and just focus on Yakuza because
what is shenmu 3 gonna be it's really
hard to put your finger on it but we
know what yaku is going to be it's it's
taking that sort of open world formula
that it actually and it's made by Sega
it's published by Sega I mean it looks
so similar to to shenmu in that regard
like the way the world looks and how you
interact with people and it's filled
with things like arcade games and UFO
catchers and all this stuff that you can
do just to [__] off and have fun in the
world yeah yeah I'm maybe that'll be my
like first full yaka game who knows it's
also the same day as Resident Evil which
I want to talk about Resident Evil sorry
pretty sick this week uh resid Evil 7
biohazard I played about four hours of
it recently for a demo at Capcom Japan I
can't say enough Good Things based on
that demo I think I played about third
of the game they told me so I have
another or a third or a quarter but I
also kind of Breeze through it because I
I just played res evil remake and again
this is like remake in first person
almost in a lot of so good at games I'm
plus I'm really [__] good at video
games so that's also Factor uh I can't
wait for this between being on psvr and
being able to swap between psvr and
regular you know standard watch playing
it on a screen that seems alluring
within the same playthrough uh the fact
that save rooms are returning there's
more you know survival saving your
bullets deciding whether to craft Health
packs or bullets uh the fact that a lot
of the you know the baker family is kind
of chasing you this is Jack Baker behind
you with a shovel right now for people
watching uh it's set in this Mansion
this like it's an old school Louisiana
Plantation a defunk plantation but this
you know cannibalistic family is chasing
you it just looks like you know that
capcom's been saying forever and we are
saying earlier on the show a lot of
developers are going back to their Roots
kind of whether it be with Zelda breath
of the wild or Doom or Resident Evil it
seems like a lot of them are kind of
getting in touch with what made the
series that they're working on great to
begin with this seems like it's an
Exemplar of that and I can't wait to
play more of it it was pretty tense but
it was also the puzzle solving was there
in Spades but also getting keys to go
through certain rooms kind of you know
like just walked through that that wall
just crumbled as he and he just stood
casually walked through it don't mind me
I'm just a Powerhouse there there is
some really goofy justification for that
in the game I will tell you but I won't
spoil it uh and then you know like the
the story structure between you're in
this Mansion as Ethan looking for your
wife or ex-wife Mia uh she's been here
for a while and you're trying to figure
out what Margaret and Jack Baker have
done with her uh and then there's Lucas
as well one of the sons there the
grandma I forget her name but you're
really getting to know these deranged
characters while you're navigating the
grounds and I already like the layout of
this Mansion is already burned into my
brain and I haven't even seen all of it
cuz I didn't get like the Scorpion key
or whatever I needed to unlock the last
three doors uh it just feel feels like a
classic Resident Evil but you know with
modern sensibilities obviously first
person is a big deal for a Resident Evil
game but I can't wait for this this will
be January 24th as well uh did you guys
get the chance to play any of this yet
rob you played a couple Dem you both
played a couple demos beginning hour and
the lantern demo that's all I've played
then the updated beginning hour to be
the midnight demo okay yeah and I played
just the lantern demo on VR and I don't
know the more I see footage the more I
think like [__] I might have a heart
attack if I played a whole game like in
VR like I don't know man I feels good
cuz you you just to aim you look yeah
wherever you want to shoot when you have
weapons uh like people kind of give VR
games with the Crouch mechanic [__] when
you just snap to but I turned it off and
like the actual Act of crouching down
the camera moving made me actually kind
of sick I don't really get motion sick
ever uh this game like snapping to have
made it much better even though it
doesn't look real but um yeah things
aside you can customize a lot of that in
VR for uh PS VR for res Evil 7 yeah but
I'm a huge advocate for that game I mean
I'm there are some people who are
stronger willed than I I know that but
like it is something
cool to be said as far as being able you
know you're you know you're being chased
and someone's looking for you with with
the Lantern and you're being able to
like you know peek through the actual
walls and do all these really like
intricate like as far as uh looks and
and ments that like I think um really
like made it more immersive and scary
yeah I talked about res Evil 7 a lot
between like podcasts and just previews
and Lobby discussions and I can't wait
for it I can't say enough about the time
I took to play it and I'm looking
forward to it uh but Pete Persona 5 I'm
not a Persona fan I don't have any
reason not to be I just haven't played
them tell me why I should be excited for
five should or should I I think that you
should um I so I really like the shin
Mega me tensei games which are sort of
an offshoot of or I guess Persona is an
offshoot of shim meamy tensei um and
Persona 4 was a sort of a an RPG that
everyone loved right um but five seems
to be delving a little bit more into
like darker themes right four was very
much about Slice of Life type things
this game is set in Tokyo and these kids
sort of like wake up to these alternate
um personalities they have called
personas these sort of like Supernatural
Alter Egos and they they delve into this
like Nether world to deal with like
adults that have like horrible like
immoral motivations and they try to like
quell that and like this game deals with
a lot of like personal and social issues
um but then it presents it with this
like bright poppy really stylish
exterior so I think it's just got like a
lot of things going for it uh both in
terms of you know the narrative the way
it looks uh and then the combat as well
which is a mix of sort of like you know
people with guns but also their
Supernatural counterparts and is it it's
turn-based combat correct yeah that's
what I assumed but yeah I'm looking
forward to it I still haven't played
Persona 4 that's been on my list for
like five years now that game is also
like 100 hours long I think you can
safely wait and just play this all right
yeah I'll do that uh another one that
you just played a few minutes ago I
think near automata yeah so the sequel
to the 2009 2010 cult classic is it even
a sequel it's just a it's a followup
it's a it's a it's got a subtitle but
near was 2010 cult classic uh just kind
of this I don't know weird open world uh
RPG with questionable action mechanics
so to correct that with automata they
brought in Platinum Games who's also
working on um you know they worked on GE
Rising they're working on scalebound
right now yeah they also did you know
metal GE Rising Revengeance and
Bayonetta but near automata P you and I
both play the demo I like this game a
lot so far yeah uh it's got that that
Platinum sort of melee combat going on
for it which uh always feels great um
and it's got an interesting presentation
that I don't even know what you'd
categorize it as it's sort of like
Gothic Jpop Meets Metal Gear kind of
yeah I guess so you're these Androids
sent down from the Moon where humans
escape to when robots took up the Earth
ex battle the robots and clear it for
humans to come back but as you can see
here your character has this sort of
like AI or little robotic buddy floating
behind her and that sort of opens up
some like arcade shooter elements uh
sort of in the way that Fury does as
well if you played that game um where
you get to go in and do close combat
with a sword but you can also fire from
afar and it all actually meshes well
together um even though the game tends
to hop around in terms of the
perspective so sometimes you're in a SES
scrolling environment other times it's a
top down perspective and then you have
the sort of you know regular third
person like 360 degree action game like
you see here it's just a really
interesting mix of mechanics and
presentation yeah the camera work was
great from the demo I played and then it
became like a bullet hell at certain
points when you're dodging projectiles
and shooting the people that are
shooting at you uh yeah to mention that
robot floating around next to you those
are that's one of the pods I believe so
you gets that let you do these like
special attacks like shoot these Spears
out in a sphere around you or just
surround yourself with these shields
that deflect you know projectiles back
at enemies yeah I I don't feel weird
making a metal gear comparison like
especially because the combat feels
similar to Rising but there's also like
an alternate skin for that robot that is
a cardboard box skin really yeah like
they're they're being subtle about it in
a way but they're also not I mean I
think this game is just going to be a
great marriage of different ideas that
just happens to have the near title yeah
I don't I don't know why I really can't
put my finger on it cuz the first game
like it's the same storyline and it's
this so this isn't yeah it's the same
like it's set I think well it's set
Millennia after the first one but it's
the same world same idea of uh you know
cyborgs being sent back down to earth to
battle robots but it's also open world
which we haven't seen obviously in the
demo the demo is this one small
bite-sized chunk uh I haven't fought
this boss he's at the end of the demo
but uh they Platinum stoed me before I
could finish it but yeah I don't know I
it seems like Platinum could just
release any game with any name and we
would know it's platinum and hope for
the best
guess um what's what's cool about this
game is that they're totally embracing
the the Japanese style for the
international release because the first
near they actually remodeled the
character for Western releases okay so
in the west we got this like really
barbaric ugly looking dude and in Japan
they got like a a pretty looking like
you know Japanese hero type I'm offended
it's it's like I don't know I mean it's
not like a huge sticking point for me
but it's just I don't know I'm glad that
Platinum can just go you know as far as
they want to into the sort of things
that they they love yeah it's one that
was under the radar for me and then I
played a demo and loved it I've been
trying to Champion it here uh we have a
demo now everybody should try it out but
yeah so those are our PS4 games uh I'm
sure we missed a few and like we said
there a lot of multiplatform on we
already talked about an Xbox one but uh
if we miss any big ones or we miss any
ones that you wanted to mention let us
know in the comments
below so that is the show today and that
is the last episode of whatever season
of the lobby this is three season
three
yeah we're up there now yeah so we'll be
starting again in a couple weeks after
the holidays and then we're back in the
office ready to start 2017 with Yakuza
zero Resident Evil 7 we have a lot of
games coming up hopefully we'll start
getting them soon I'm looking forward to
but I have a lot of holiday games to
finish up do you guys have any like
backlog games you're planning on over
the holiday yeah dude I mean like what
I'm sure you do what are the ones you're
really trying to get through Titanfall 2
I got multiplayer that much yet not as
much as I'd like no uh so many man like
I think one of the ones that uh I had to
like kind of rip the Band-Aid on and
play other ones was uh uh I want to
finish the Witcher blood and wine oh
yeah like I was having a great time with
that and then had to put it down and
that's a game where it's like okay let's
see my calendar how's it looking for the
next two weeks because it's not a game
that you know it takes about 30 minutes
just to like go through my inventory and
and remember what the hell I was doing
with that broadsword you know what I
mean like that [__] is taxing but uh God
yeah there are a lot that I would say I
can't think of anything right now yeah
so I finally got like pass halfway in
The Last Guardian and I against my
wishes I have started to like that game
a lot like people kept telling me that
there would be a point and just to be
stubborn I was like no I still don't
like it and then like last night I was
like all right I like it Trio's all
right's pretty good Trio's pretty cool
pretty cool the boy is annoying me now
though so I'm just I'm finding things to
annoy me but no I I really
like
Tio I don't even know what he's said too
too it's Japanese for prisoner I think
really is that where Trio comes from
it's a derivation of that yeah gotcha
what are you playing man I don't know
put me on the spot there's a lot of have
reviews coming up over the holiday won't
you I'll probably be playing yaka zero
word yeah gotcha yep yeah probably
finish up Last Guardian this week and
then finish up Final Fantasy yeah I got
to the end of Dishonor 2 and I really
like this honor too I'm happy I finally
plowed through that I keep seeing people
saying that they're they've beat Final
Fantasy by showing the sort of like end
slate that you get after you beat the
game but man there's so much more to
that game I feel like I want people to
just rush through the story and keep
playing the other stuff sounds like what
like a bachelor's degree offers in like
real life oh man oh really no that's
they got $100,000 that's the associates
degree to get your Bachelor you actually
have to play 60 hours yeah your Masters
you have to take down that Turtle God
thing maybe I'll do that maybe that'll
be no I'm not going to if you do are you
are you really going to try that no or
what's that what's that one dungeon
that's like people say will never ever
get navigated all the way oh the crazy
puzzle one yeah there's like a in the
official strategy guide which we got to
like try to make some guide content for
the site it has a section for that
dungeon it says this is too complex to
represent with words and images you have
to watch a video here's a URL oh my God
it's not good uh I don't know if I want
to do that I've already put in like 75
hours in that game so I've got a lot
think you done there's a lot of games I
want to go back to the division is
probably number one yeah survival mode
sounds awesome surval mode darkest
dungeon which like I really regret like
not putting it or at least like bringing
it up more during game of the year
because it was so early in the year um
then what else like just something uh
res Evil 4 hyperlight Drifter Hy Drifter
that's a great game you should play that
I was telling him once I having seen a
lot of the art style I watched uh the
opening uh scene of that game Madness
blew my mind and then when I saw
gameplay of uh I wasn't sure what that
game was it reminded me a lot of I can't
remember um transistor which I respect
but I didn't know if I could like invest
time to it but right when I saw uh the
map layout of hyper light Drifter I was
like oh this is Zelda like done like
downloaded so I can't wait play that one
yeah that game's
great all right anyway that's a show uh
last of the year so we were looking
forward to starting next year but this
whole week uh Game of the Year stuff is
winding down we're going to be
publishing it but we're almost done
working on it so we will be publishing
that for everybody the next few weeks
our top 25 games will be coming out
we're doing it a bit differently this
year so Monday December 20th we are
going to be doing a five hour live
stream from 10: a.m. till 300 p.m. so at
10: we're going to announce number five
game of the year and then we're going to
right after we do this like we did a
Lobby set discussion right after we uh
show that on the stream here on Twitch
or Gamespot wherever you want to watch
it we're going to be playing the game
for another hour a few of us uh and then
we're going to show some videos that
were made about it throughout the year
whether they're Fe fees or whether there
maybe the video review will be shown
then game four will be at 11:00 a.m.
12:00 p.m. and so forth number one game
will be announced 2 pm usually the time
of the lobby but again this is the last
episode so that's when we're going to
announce our game of the year so stick
around for that we have a lot going on
uh Tuesday December 20th it'll be pretty
tiring uh Pete and I will be swapping
out to host Rob will be on a bunch of
the segments we'll pretty much try to
get as many games spot people through
here to talk about the games as possible
um then we also have a space Hulk stream
some point this week I think today lat
Wednesday whiches tomorrow tomorrow
morning spacehulk is four player co-op I
that Mar are going to play that maybe
some other people in the office will
join in but that game looks pretty cool
and yeah I'll I'll sit in with you guys
oh awesome awes and later on today I
think bully Scott and somebody is going
to be playing Bully it's backwards
compatible now but it's also like in the
December sale for PS4 interestingly
enough so I guess it's just like a good
time to play bully it's always a good
time uh yeah but then we have we have I
feel like we have a lot of streams
there's going to be a battlefield the
new DLC we're getting soon so we'll
probably stream that this week we're
going be doing a lot of live streams is
my main point because it's winding down
here at the gam spot office anyway as
always thank you to John Luke in the
back Mary in the back Eric Tay Richard
Lee was not here on camera today but U
he usually does a great job anyway thank
you so much for uh joining us every
episode of this season it's been great
being the host uh in the absence of
Danny OD DWI I'm sure we'll keep getting
Rob and Pete on here a lot no but uh
yeah we look forward to seeing you
during that game of the year live stream
and if you can't make it we will see you
next
[Music]
year